the idea of a Nash equilibrium is
important enough that I think it
deserves its own video and you may or
may not know it's named for John Nash
who was played by Russell Crowe in the
movie A Beautiful Mind and it's a it's a
game theoretical concept and you know
game theory sounds very fancy but it
really is just the theory of games and
this prisoner's dilemma that we talked
about in the previous video really is a
game this the different players have
different strategies and based on their
interacting strategies you end up in
different states you end up with
different outcomes and here's a
definition of Nash equilibrium from
Princeton and that's a good place to get
the definition because that's where John
Nash spent a good bit of his career and
it is defined or this definition says
it's a stable state of a system that
involves several interacting
participants in our prisoner's dilemma
we had two participants in which no no
participant can gain by a change of
strategy as long as all the other
participants remain unchanged so let's
think about the different states of this
system right over here and think of
whether they are whether any of them
meet this criteria so let's say let me
number this one let's say that is state
1 this is state 2 this is state 3 and
this is state 4 right over here so if we
are sitting if we are sitting in state 1
if we are sitting in state 1 can any of
the participants change could change
their strategy can gain by changing the
strategy assuming the other participant
is constant so if we are sitting here in
state one right over here so Al is
denying and Bill is denying well Al can
improve his Al can have can improve his
situation by changing his strategy he
can go from denying which is the
scenario here to confessing so al can
change his strategy and gain or you
could go with the other way zooming bill
was constant in the denial or you could
go the other way if we're sitting here
in state four you're sitting here in
state four and we assume Alice constant
bill can improve his situation by going
from a denial to a confession he can go
from two year to one year so for both of
those reasons if either of those were
true this would not
Nash equilibrium but both of those are
true so this is definitely not a Nash
equilibrium so not not a Nash
equilibrium I gave two examples in which
a participant can can gain by a change
of strategy as long as the other
participant remains unchanged this move
was one example and this this was a move
by Al with bills denial constant this
was a move by Bill with Al's denial
constant not a Nash equilibrium now
let's think about now let's think about
state two if we are sitting in state two
if we are sitting in state two can
assuming bill is constant can al change
to improve his outcome so can L change
to improve his outcome in state two al
is only getting one year if al goes from
a confession to a denial he's going to
get two years so al cannot change his
cannot change his strategy and get again
here so so far it's looking good but
let's think of it from Bill's point of
view so if we are in state two if we are
in state two right over here and we
assume a Liz constant can bill do
something that changes things
well sure bill can go from denying to
confessing if he goes from denying to
confessing he goes from 10 years in
prison to 3 years in prison so I've
given an example of a participant who
can gain by a change of strategy as long
as all the other participants remain
unchanged both of them don't have to be
able to do this you just need to have
one of them for it to not be a Nash
equilibrium
because bill can have a gain by a change
of strategy holding Al's strategy
constant so holding Al strategy in the
confession then this is not a not Nash
equilibrium so this is not Nash because
you have this movement can occur to a
more favorable state for bill holding al
constant now let's go to state 3 let's
think about this so if we're in state 3
so this is this is Bill confessing and
Al denying so let's first think about
Al's point of view if we if we assume
Bill is constant in his confession can
al improve his scenario well sure he can
go from denying which is what would have
to be in
three two confessing so he could move he
could move in this direction right over
here and that by itself is enough
evidence that this is not a Nash
equilibrium we don't even have to think
about Bill its symmetric there's
actually nothing that bill could do in
this scenario holding al constant that
could improve things bill would not want
to go from here to here but just by the
fact that al could go from here to here
holding bill constant tells you that
this is not this is not a Nash
equilibrium now let's go to scenario
four and you know where this is going
because you watch the last video but now
it's a little I'm going through it a
little bit in more detail in state four
they are both confessing now let's look
at it from Al's point of view and we're
going to hold bill constant we're going
to hold bill unchanged so we're gonna
have to stay in this column we're going
to say that assume that bill is
confessing from Al's point of view if we
are in state one can he change his
strategy to get a better outcome well
the only thing he could do is go from a
confession to a denial but that's not
going to do good he's going to go from
three years to ten years so al al can't
al cannot gain by a change of strategy
as long as all their participants remain
unchanged now let's think about it from
Bill's point of view we're in this state
right over here we're going to assume
that Alice constant that al is in the
confession confession mode so bill right
now in state four is confessing his only
option is to deny but by doing that
he'll go from three years in prison to
ten years in prison so he's not going to
gain so he too cannot gain so we've just
found a state in state four in which no
participant can gain by a change of
strategy as long as all other
participants remain unchanged and this
part is important because we're not
saying that both can change
simultaneously be aware you are not in
this payoff matrix allowing a diagonal
move and so no participant can gain need
neither Al nor bill holding the other
one constant this is a Nash Nash
equilibrium equilibrium this one right
here and this is a stable state